now to this developing story today eight
people are dead and
several others were injured after a
gunman opened fire at a fedex facility
in indianapolis overnight before turning
the gun on himself
the fbi is now assisting local police
there with this investigation
charlie demar reports for us from
indianapolis they have an active shooter
currently at fedex
the late night shooting unfolded at a
fedex facility near the indianapolis
international airport there was no
confrontation
with anyone that was there there was no
disturbance there was no argument
he just appeared to randomly start
shooting
and that began in the parking lot and
then he did go
into the building into the facility for
a brief period of time
police say when they arrived they
encountered the shooter who ultimately
took his life they found several victims
injured
and several victims deceased as well as
the suspect
witnesses described a chaotic scene i
saw
a assault rifle of some sort
i saw the clip and he started firing
jeremiah miller
was outside the facility about to start
his second shift
when he heard the gunfire i hear six
shots fired at once
you know you know at a time bang bang
bang bang bang bang
he says he took cover then started
warning other employees
my initial thought was don't die
and escape but then when i started
seeing everybody roll up
from midnight shift i felt the need to
help people
i felt the need to warn people multiple
bullets even struck this car in the
parking lot
blowing out its windows after the
shooting facility workers were rushed
into buses
and taken to a nearby hotel to reunite
with anxious loved ones
charisse grice wasn't able to get a hold
of her nephew raymond who was inside
during the shooting
we've been calling this phone texting
them like they said their phones are
locked up they can't have them on them
at work
so we don't know if he okay or not the
hospitals can tell us nothing
no police officers were injured
investigators still at the scene
trying to determine a motive jeremiah
you just heard from says fedex employees
can't bring their cell phones into the
facility and he worries that may have
cost
precious seconds fedex says that they
are working
with authorities charlie demar cbs news
indianapolis